[موسيقى]
لذلك نحن هنا في
Shamsher.  أشعر بالإثارة ،
كم هو كل هذا ونحن ننظر إليه
هو صورة نمطية في هونغ كونغ أو إلى أي مدى
حقيقي هذا هو المكان الذي يأتي فيه الناس.
الارتباك في اندماج التحديث الحديث
حول تحديث الأشياء التي تفكر في
الأشياء لتصبح متقدمة على أنفسنا ، يا شباب
مثلي ، نحتاج إلى المجيء إلى هنا
وتذكر تقريبًا من أين
أتينا من هذا هو المكان
الذي احتفظوا فيه بالتقاليد
واستمروا في جعل الأمور على الطريق  أنهم
اعتادوا على جعلهم
متجر المعكرونة قاب قوسين أو أدنى إذا
قام بتغيير وصفة المعكرونة الخاصة به ، يمكنك الآن تقضم جميع المعكرونة
[الموسيقى]
وإحكام غطائها - لذا تأتي هذه الأشياء
من فضلك تعال ،
لقد حصلت على ملعقة فقط -
لتلتقطها  أنا  بملعقتك
قليلاً ، نعم ، يمكنك المساعدة بزاوية
ثم وضع فمك في فمك
لم أستخدم دراجتي أبدًا تقريبًا ، لقد
حصلت على القليل من
الأسلوب الياباني هناك ، أرى أنني
أحب هذا الانصهار  الهدف ليس
الحصول عليه على ملابسك في حالة
جيدة